oui déjà un an souvenez vous ils se
mariaient nous étions là
madame et monsieur traitons le couple
ouvriers de villejuif
madame et monsieur martineau le couple
agriculteurs de son vieux près de lyon
madame et monsieur girard dont le couple
parisien
qu'est-ce qui les avait amenés là vers
l'autre
une imagination sa démo vient
il était bien et nous sommes toujours
bien accordé
parce que j'ai trouvé qu'ils hrw
l'onglet marland grande ou comment vous
êtes-vous connu et
au cours d'un rallye automobile ont fait
ensemble
dans un bal près du village à trois
kilomètres de saint-martin il ya combien
il ya trois quatre ans mais enfin il ya
deux ans que nous ferons qu'un temps
c'est connu exactement
dans la rue comme ça 20 36 ans range mon
agent a jeté son journal
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé à ce moment
là exactement
ben
moi la veille
c'est difficile à cet avis voulez vous
des enfants oui
mais pas tout de suite
combien monsieur chacun autres pour dire
d'occuper un peu la maison nous
distraire
si souvent commencé
quel est le premier achat que vous
envisagez de faire ensemble une machine
à coudre
pour le moment peut-être pas beaucoup
mais d'ici quelques temps ça fait
mal gérard larcher
marché pour manger la cuisine
mais comme
à chaque cours on pense acheter une
voiture on pense acheter un appareil de
photo on pense acheter une chambre à
coucher une salle à manger
vous avez déjà pensé pense du ménage et
où l on peut dans un frigidaire n'est
pas là maintenant et le reste je veux
pas autre chose voilà donc vous irez
faire votre marché c'est la première des
jeunes français j'espère qu'il sera bon
et pas trop cher merci
c'était il ya un an les girardon
attendre qu'un enfant les traitons son
discret à ce sujet
quant aux martineau ils ont qu un bébé
trois couples un ans de vie conjugale
que leur est il arrivé d'importants
pendant ce temps
rien d'exceptionnel
pour grand chose aux femmes êtes vous
heureuse madame da tendance est enfant
oui très heureux et puisqu'une une
dédiée lyon
et vous monsieur homo j espère bien que
c'est le premier d'une oeuvre d'une
série
et vous non nous avons tout de suite que
je profite un peu de la vie qu les deux
puisqu'on sait marier jeune
l'existence à 2 at elle facilité votre
vie
des lendemains de notre mariage nous
commencions n'ont pas compté très juste
si vous voulez mais à faire attention à
ce que nous dépensions de façon dès le
premier jour a tâché d'acquérir des
réserves pour plus tard maintenant je
rentre le soir il fait froid faut
allumer le feu
il faut faire surtout les faux mission
enfin ça ce sont des petits détails
pratiques ce je pense que votre femme et
bien
c'est plutôt moi qui ai laine
vous êtes vous découvert mutuellement
des défauts que vous ignoriez
non je n'ai pas découvert et puis même
si j'en aurai découvert voulait dire est
forte seul défaut que ma femme à ce
qu'elle a toujours souri je ne pensais
que une femme
aurait dû savoir faire la cuisine ou
plus mais maintenant une femme va
travailler
mécanographe
jamais fait cuisine chez sa mère
maintenant c'est ça viendra
pas qu
il y a un an vous nous aviez dit que
l'homme devait être le maître à la
maison
le regrettez vous
mais jusqu'au qu'on peut dire que nous
sommes des
déjà un peu organisée si vous voulez
chacun a sa partie ce qui est une façon
de ne pas marcher sur les plates-bandes
de l'autre la femme s'occupe de toutes
les questions des gens qu'on à recevoir
de des achats relatifs à l'intérieur et
c'est
moi je m'occupe des
décisions si vous les plus importantes à
prendre au point de vue de l'éducation
des enfants par exemple c'est certain et
c'est moi qui prendrai les décisions
non je crois que l'on commande tous les
deux à vrai dire il n'a pas eu plus que
l'autre qui commande enfin vous marier
quand même plus vieux que moi
il domine quand même un petit peu
enfin je réussis toujours avoir ce que
je veux quand même moi je crois que
c'est moi qui peux m'en
vous pensiez que la femme devait rester
à la maison avez vous changé d'avis
bon allez pas forcément de rester à la
maison peut sortir d'un riche en
six jours mais je connais enfin des gens
chez qui la femme gagne assez largement
sa vie travail au dehors et à une femme
de ménage pour s'occuper de son ménage
et de ses enfants mais à mon avis c'est
pas le rôle d'une femme puisque vous
voulez
qui on veut arriver quelque chose
maintenant il faut qu'ils travaillent
dites moi votre premier achat at il été
celui que vous aviez prévu lequel
nous sommes partis en vacances tous les
deux ça a été la grosse dépense on a
acheté une voiture fait en étant en
vacances
vous êtes content madame de la voiture
votre mariage
oui enfin ça une licence
qui vous le laisse prendre
une fois j conduite
60 à l'heure
quels sont les petits travers qui vous
agacent le plus chez l'un ou chez
l'autre
il est souvent en train de l'embêter
quand je fais mon travail dans chaque
set 15 mai
jacquot de points nous bien rangé
je suis pour les papiers tout ça alors
là il ya son affaire grand chat même si
on arrive à roujan et demi ça lui prend
danger et papiers
granger papier
je suis assez méticuleux j'aime bien que
les choses soient rangés exactement à
leur place et cetera
s'il arrive que ma femme et qui je vous
le disais n'a pas que ça à faire
remède pas une chose à sa place et bien
je peux je peux d'ailleurs très bien
passé deux ou trois jours sans s'en
apercevoir mais quand je m'en aperçois
ça nous sommes fichus en boule est ce
que vous pensez toujours que votre femme
ressemble à michael
moore c'est à dire que
en vouloir mais depuis qu'elle s'est
mariée à la loi aussi un peu
pensez vous que votre mari toujours au
nom vous dit tout je trouve plus du tout
qui ressemble à un moment non pourquoi
pas d'abord il a maigri
et voilà un an déjà quelques illusions
perdues quelques vérités gagner un
équilibre que l'on acquiert petit à
petit la route est longue mais le
bonheur est au bout
[Musique]